bonjour Yves roblique merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin aussi un
policier vous avez notamment dirigé la
BRI la brigade antigang comme on
l'appelle vous en avez fait un livre les
secrets de l'antigang flic indique et
qu'autordu écrit en collaboration avec
Frédéric Ploquin et s'est aux éditions
plomb vous êtes un grand nombre de la
police Yves Jobic d'une police comme on
en fait plus c'est ce qu'on ressent en
lisant votre livre vous y êtes entré il
y a près de 40 ans dont 20 ans de police
judiciaire et vous venez de prendre
votre retraite comment évoluer la police
selon vous
alors la police que j'ai connue en
rentrant en 1983 donc été celle du quai
des Orfèvres donc c'était la police
judiciaire parisienne que j'ai voulu
intégrer en sortant de l'école des
commissaires de police pour faire de la
police judiciaire voilà donc j'ai pu
m'épanouir pendant plusieurs dizaines
d'années dans plusieurs services du quai
des Orfèvres avec une hiérarchie qui à
l'époque avait une vision très dynamique
de lutte contre la criminalité
un recours aux sources humaines en y
reviendra peut-être
voilà une occupation du terrain par les
3300 fonctionnaires qui composaient la
police judiciaire parisienne
il y a eu un grand virage en 1999 dont
je parle dans mon livre qui a été une
réforme
où on a cassé entre en quelque sorte le
quai des orphelins oui sous la houlette
de Jean-Pierre Chevènement mais je ne
suis pas sûr que c'est soit vraiment lui
qui était à l'origine de la réforme dans
les détails c'est à l'occasion de la
création de la pollution urbaine de
proximité où on a à enlever la police
judiciaire le tiers de ses effectifs et
pour vous oui parce que on a enlevé les
commissariats de quartier
d'arrondissement qui constituait la base
de l'édifice pour les transférer la
sécurité publique pour créer une
nouvelle direction la police urbaine de
proximité voilà donc on a coupé la
police judiciaire de ces services de
terrain
de ces capteurs de terrain qui
permettaient d'avoir accès à toutes les
informations et des faits remonter
on comprend bien en lisant votre livre
que pour vous l'efficacité de la police
elle repose sur l'humain sur le
renseignement humain est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il est toujours aussi
efficace se renseignement humain ou
est-ce qu'il a été affaibli par
différentes réformes alors le
renseignement humain quand je suis
rentré je vous disais le recours aux
sources humaines faisait vraiment partie
de la culture du quai des Orfèvres mais
également de la police judiciaire de la
DCPJ mais au sein du 36 le quai des
Orfèvres étaient une machine de guerre
contre le banditisme très puissant 3300
fonctionnaires commissaires et
inspecteurs un recours systématique aux
sources humaines qui permettait de faire
des affaires d'initiatives et de
solutionner des affaires criminelles
voilà donc moi dans les services que
j'ai dirigé que ce soit en division de
police judiciaire ou à la BRI le recours
aux informateurs a permis de réussir des
affaires très importantes
mais également de sauver des vies
humaines puisque nous avons pu arrêter
Jean-Claude Bonal surnommé le chinois
qui avait tué six personnes en 10 jours
en 2001
donc pour moi le
la source humaine est au cœur du
dispositif et il faut revenir à ce
dispositif parce qu'il faut savoir ce
qui se passe dans le milieu il faut
savoir qui fait quoi qui travaille avec
qui qui prépare quel coup qui a fait
telle opération pour pouvoir ensuite
faire des interpellations parce que
sinon la police est aveugle elle est
sourde et elle ne peut pas avoir de
résultats et la base de tous sont les
indices ce qu'on appelle les
comment on travaille avec un indice
qu'est-ce qu'il apporte aux policiers
lundi concrètement alors l'indique
permet de savoir ce qui se passe dans le
milieu donc c'est un capteur il fait le
plus souvent partie lui-même du milieu
en général
moi-même j'ai été formé pour le
traitement des indics parce qu'il y a
une manière de traiter des informations
en fait moi j'étais formé sur le tas par
des inspecteurs des visionnaires par
deux inspecteurs de visionnaires
particulières qui étaient deux des
policiers parisiens les murs enseignés
donc il y avait eux-mêmes un
portefeuille d'indique très développé
qui m'ont transmis leur savoir donc il y
a des règles de sécurité à respecter et
alors en particulier toujours informé sa
hiérarchie de l'identité des
informations que l'on a il faut que ce
soit le policier qui manipule l'indique
et pas le contraire
et ça ça arrive ça peut arriver
ça ne doit pas arriver voilà et il faut
aussi et surtout que
comme dans une négociation commerciale
du win-win il faut que
l'avantage pour la police soit très
largement supérieur à ce que l'on
autorise entre guillemets l'informateur
à voir comme activité
bordariline ou très plus que borderline
voilà donc ça je l'explique dans mon
livre enfin il y a un certain nombre de
règles de sécurité respectées et voilà
donc c'est plus compliqué pour les flics
aujourd'hui de se servir d'indique
est-ce qu'il y a des choses que vous
faisiez vous à l'époque et qui ne sont
plus possibles aujourd'hui alors moi
quand je quand j'exerçais
les indics n'avaient pas d'existence
officielle puisque c'est la loi perven 2
en 2004 qui a donné à l'indique enfin
aux informateurs un statut officiel ils
sont immatriculés ils sont rémunérés
selon le bon le l'importance des
affaires qu'ils amènent
on a freiner certains
en matière de stupéfiant je pense que
l'immatriculation des indics ne pose
aucun problème c'est même une sécurité
c'est même une très bonne chose par
contre moi j'ai eu et j'ai des collègues
qui ont eu des
informateurs qui faisaient partie du
grand banditisme il est clair que un
voyou fichu au grand banditisme ne va
pas accepter d'être immatriculé parce
que ça présente plusieurs risques
notamment il n'est pas l'abri qu'un jour
un juge d'instruction face une
perquisition dans le fichier des
informateurs de la police
voir que des hackers pénètre ce fichier
là bon avec toutes les conséquences
dramatiques que ça peut avoir pour la
source donc il faut là aussi de mon
point de vue protéger des indics il faut
en avoir il faut les protéger la société
d'ailleurs doit protéger les
informations d'ailleurs dans mon livre
au début je dédicace le livre à mes
collaborateurs avec qui j'ai eu
l'honneur de travail aux policiers
retraités aux actuels et aussi au sens
humaines qui nous ont permis donc de
d'aider la société de la protéger
il y a des choses que moi je faisais à
l'époque et qui était quand même pas mal
mais qui n'est plus possible de faire
aujourd'hui alors nous avions beaucoup
plus de souplesse ça c'est très clair
qu'il y ait eu des garde-fous
d'instaurer c'est une très bonne chose
maintenant
la doctrine
en matière d'indique n'a pas forcément
été rédigé par des policiers qui avaient
une forte expérience dans le domaine et
c'est un euphémisme
parce que bon
ce n'est pas depuis un bureau que l'on
peut expliquer ou comprendre comment on
doit gérer un indique qu'on est dans
l'humain on est dans la psychologie on
est dans les rapports de confiance
il faut toujours faire très attention
c'est pour ça que je vous disais que la
hiérarchie moi ma hiérarchie a toujours
été informé en temps réel de l'identité
de mes informations voilà donc je pense
que effectivement c'est bien d'avoir
immatriculé enfin fin dispositif on est
peut-être allé un peu trop loin
sur les évolution de la police puisque
votre livre c'est aussi un regard sur
l'évolution de la police est-ce que vous
le dites est-ce que il y a il y a trop
d'administratifs aujourd'hui trop de
paperasses et du coup des policiers qui
ne passent pas assez de temps à faire
des enquêtes à être sur le terrain
la police c'est bureaucratisée alors
c'est un petit peu à l'image de la
société
c'est à dire que au lieu d'avoir une
police musclée dynamique bon pour
arrêter maintenant un voyou il faut
presque remplir 10 imprimés
il faut ouvrir plusieurs parapluies donc
nous avions beaucoup plus de liberté de
l'attitude alors ça venait aussi du fait
que nous avions la totale confiance des
magistrats à l'époque quand j'ai
commencé le couple police justice à
Paris fonctionnait à merveille
c'est-à-dire que les magistrats qui
n'allaient pas sur le terrain qu'il soit
du parquet ou des juges d'instruction
faisait une confiance totale
à moins que évidemment on leur cache des
choses et que on leur
des histoires mais ce qui était rare ici
mais auquel cas bon la confiance était
rompue mais le couple fonctionnait très
très bien
alors c'est malheureusement beaucoup
moins de cas je pense qu'il y a une
histoire de génération de magistrats
je ne connais pas la formation qui est
faite à les nm en la matière mais il est
clair que pour que la sécurité
fonctionne en France enfin pour que la
prestation matière de sécurité
fonctionne bien il faut que ce couple
Polisse justice refonctionne
parfaitement et il faut qu'il y ait des
relations de confiance ce qui est le cas
en quand même en général entre des
magistrats et la police judiciaire des
policiers spécialisés en général bon les
magistrats connaissent les policiers des
services spécialisés donc ils ont
l'habitude de travailler ensemble mais
on devrait aller vers du mieux améliorer
cette relation on est dans une on est
jusqu'à arriver à une opposition
aujourd'hui entre police et justice on
est dans une confrontation alors il y
avait une confiance quasi totale bon ce
qui fait que c'est un plaisir de
travailler enfin il y avait bon on
travaillait en parfaite harmonie
maintenant il y a plus une défiance
de la part de certains envers la police
notamment sur des méthodes de travail
moi je l'ai vécu en fait dans mon
affaire ça a été le cas puisque j'étais
intervenu pour un informateur
qui avait été interpellé avec une faible
quantité de stupéfiants de cannabis et
cette intervention a été mal perçue par
le juge d'instruction qui a nourri une
défiance envers mon service et moi-même
donc après l'affaire s'est emballée mais
voilà oui effectivement je pense que on
doit revenir à des relations de
confiance parce qu'on entend des
policiers dire voilà nous on travaille
on arrête les gens sur le terrain et
puis on les retrouve lâcher quelques
heures plus tard alors ce sont deux
choses différentes à mon avis la police
la justice n'a pas forcément les moyens
de travailler elle est
embolisée par les dossiers donc là je il
est évident que ça n'est pas la faute
qui sera qui croule sous les dossiers
donc bon les prisons aussi sont pleines
en manque de place de prison
actuellement
il a été promis la création d'un certain
nombre de places qui pour l'instant je
crois n'ont pas vu le jour voilà donc là
dans ce domaine-là les magistrats sont
victimes et il est parfois donc
injuste de leur faire le reproche de ne
pas être assez sévère puisqu'ils n'ont
pas les moyens la défiance c'est autre
chose c'est quand on fait des enquêtes
sur le banditisme bon il faut que les
magistrats qui sont concernés fassent
confiance aux enquêteurs qui sont des
gens sérieux professionnels et qui
travaille très bien il y a une réforme
qui fait Cambri en ce moment bien sûr
c'est la réforme de la police judiciaire
quai de regroupé tous les services sous
l'autorité d'un directeur départemental
qui serait dépendant du préfet pourquoi
vous êtes opposé à cette réforme vous
alors je ne suis pas le seul à être
[Musique]
à cette réforme puisque
la magistrature ce qui est assez rare à
Émilie un avis assez critique de la même
manière les magistrats des Gires c'est
juridictions interagiales spécialisées
qui fait un travail remarquable avec les
services régionaux aux zones de police
judiciaire sont très inquiets puisqu'ils
n'auront plus d'interlocuteurs alors
pourquoi je suis inquiet c'est parce que
Clémenceau avait créé la police
judiciaire en 1907 déjà à l'époque et
puisqu'il s'était rendu compte que les
malfaiteurs travaillaient opérés au-delà
de l'échelle d'un département voilà donc
on avait créé des brigades mobiles qui
avaient une compétence sur plusieurs
départements là avec cette réforme on
veut effectivement vous l'avez dit
placer sous l'autorité d'un directeur
départemental de la police nationale qui
sera dans
99% des cas issus de la sécurité
publique
donc ça sera en généraliste qui nous
rend ni la culture ni la formation de
l'investigation on va placer tous les
effectifs de police du département pour
les judiciaire police aux frontières
sécurité publique pour former un tout et
on va donc faire absorber les actuels
enquêteurs de la police judiciaire dans
cette nouvelle architecture pour venir
renforcer les officiers de police
judiciaire des commissariats
principalement qui sont débordés pour
travailler sur la petite et la moyenne
délinquance et donc
ces enquêteurs hyper compétents de la
police judiciaire vont être obligés de
délaisser leur cœur de métier qui est la
criminalité organisée donc les trafics
de stupéfiants les trafics d'arbres
trafic de véhicules trafic des êtres
humains mais aussi toute la délinquance
économique et financière corruption
éventuellement corruption des élus
contact enfin avec la mafia côté
correctement avec cette réforme de la
paix judiciaire pour vous non parce
qu'on va faire basculer ces 5000
fonctionnaires spécialisés vers de la
petite et moyenne des languence donc ils
n'auront plus ni le temps ni les moyens
et ils seront cantonnés à une échelle de
département et comme je vous l'ai dit le
département les voyous actuellement
classiquement et tous les jours des
bords de l'échelle du département voilà
alors il y a une autre conséquence
mécanique c'est que actuellement les
délinquants qui sortent de garde à vue
d'un service de police judiciaire dans
90% des cas sont incarcérés en sécurité
publique donc demain en ddpn le ratio
est totalement inverse c'est 10% des
gens qui sortent de garde à vue qui sont
de s'écroués donc on va avoir
mécaniquement une baisse des
incarcérations en France très nette qui
va se traduire par le fait que
ces criminels professionnels vont avoir
le champ libre puisqu'ils rend plus
d'une part
surface 2 des policiers qui vont les
combattre et ils auront beaucoup moins
de risques de d'aller en prison ça veut
dire que c'est un danger pour la
sécurité des Français aussi
c'est surtout ça enfin je pense que ce
qui motive la vie des professionnels des
5000 professionnels dont je signale
d'ailleurs qu'ils ont créé une
association l'association nationale de
la police judiciaire qui regroupe
plusieurs milliers de
d'officiers
donc elle est représentative je sais
qu'elle a demandé à rencontrer le
ministre géraldal Darmanin qui pour
l'instant n'a pas souhaité les recevoir
au motif que ce n'est pas un syndicat et
je pense que dans un souci de
transparence et de discussion et pour
essayer de sortir vers le haut de
trouver peut-être des réglages des
solutions je pense que le ministre
devrait rencontrer les représentants de
cette association qui sont des gens très
sérieux qui ont manifesté c'est vrai ces
dernières semaines et notamment à
Marseille lors des Accords pour cette
réforme ce qu'on a appelé cette haie du
déshonneur alors il se trouve que je
connais très bien ericarella qui est un
très très grand professionnel je pense
d'ailleurs que c'est lui qui aurait il y
a quelques années être dû nommé il
aurait dû être nommé directeur central
de la police judiciaire parce que le
patron pour Marseille et la zone
il a été écarté
il était écarté de manière assez brutale
d'ailleurs je ne comprends pas bon
d'autant que ça n'est pas lui qui était
à l'origine de ce mouvement de ses
collaborateurs
alors en tout cas il a il a sacrifié sur
l'hôtel de la réforme
erika est là qui restera dans l'histoire
comme étant un grand flic qui a été qui
a été sacrifié qui en a coupé la tête et
je pense qu'en effet ça a été une malade
de la part du ministre et je crois que
pour rattraper parce qu'il faut essayer
de s'en sortir vers le haut
les gens de la NPJ ont des choses très
importantes à exposer il y a peut-être
des malentendus de part et d'autre et il
faut avancer donc je crois que il la
comprend quand je vous ai posé la
question mais tout de suite parler de
Clémenceau Gérald Darmanin lui dit mais
on est plus autant de Clémenceau est-ce
qu'il comprend bien cette institution
cette police judiciaire selon vos Gérald
Darmanin alors je crois que d'une
manière générale les politiques ne
comprennent pas très bien la police
judiciaire vous savez c'est assez
compliqué en fait un ministre notamment
le musée de l'Intérieur n'a pas que la
police à s'occuper il a d'autres il a
les élections les culte et d'autres
attributions très importantes mais
Jean-Pierre Chevènement lorsqu'on a
cassé le quai des Orfèvres en 99 ça
n'est pas lui qui avait eu l'idée de
cette réforme elle lui avait été
proposée par des gens bon que nous
connaissons que je connais très bien qui
par ailleurs sont des amis mais qui sont
des gens de la sécurité publique voilà
et les résultats de cette réforme à
Paris en le voit sur depuis des années
ne sont pas bons de la même manière
cette réforme a été proposée à Gérald
Darmanin avec des arguments apparemment
positifs sur certains plans mais
concernant l'intégration de la police
judiciaire dans le dispositif ce que
donc Pierre Joxe n'avait pas voulu faire
en 91 je pense qu'il y a là une erreur
et qui n'est pas trop tard pour corriger
le tir et faire des réglages c'est une
réforme qui vous l'avez dit va faire
prospérer la grande criminalité de facto
ça aussi ça fait partie de vos
inquiétudes vous dites aujourd'hui il y
a une mafia en France encore aujourd'hui
alors il y a une criminalité organisée
qui est combattue au jour le jour par
ces enquêteurs spécialisés
à un niveau inférieur par les gens des
sûretés départementales qui travaillent
donc en sécurité lui qui font aussi un
très un excellent travail mais un niveau
moindre du spectre de la délinquance
donc il est clair que les
criminels les mafia sont présentes sont
actives mais on les contrôle pour
l'instant
oui sur le territoire oui oui je dirais
qu'on est contrôles mais demain il est
clair qu'elles auront le champ libre
devant elle pour travailler j'ai
toujours des contacts dans le milieu par
certaines de mes ex informateurs qui me
tiennent au courant et qui sont très
surpris de cette réforme et qui me
disent mais ils vont autour de nous les
les voyous nos collègues
n'en croient pas leurs yeux et se
frottent déjà les mains à l'idée que
cette réforme voit le jour parce qu'ils
savent que ils n'auront plus en phase 2
des policiers spécialisés pour les
combattre donc ça veut dire que cette
grande criminalité cette matière de la
contrôlera plus demain avec cette
réforme avec les conséquences tout à
fait alors on pourrait faire le parler
avec la médecine c'est comme si on
supprimait les spécialistes pour venir
renforcer des généralistes au motif que
on manque de généraliste sur le
territoire
alors le renfort des spécialistes qui
deviendraient des généralistes
permettraient d'améliorer peut-être un
peu les choses mais vous l'avez bien
compris toutes les maladies cardio des
cardiologues dermato gynéco et ainsi de
suite
ne pourrait plus traiter leur maladie et
forcément
on traiterait des petits bobos mais des
maladies plus graves donc
s'installeraient prospère aurait et ce
qui est aussi serait très grave elle a
évolué vous la connaissez bien cette
grande criminalité on comprend lisant
votre livre elle a évolué est-ce qu'il y
a aujourd'hui de nouveaux codes dans
cette criminalité alors des cours à vrai
dire le code d'honneur des je le dis
dans mon livre bon le code d'honneur des
voyous c'est une c'est une vaste blague
puisque
très peu de voyous respectent un code
d'honneur j'en ai connu j'en ai
rencontré il y en a mais on peut
décompter sur les doigts d'une main donc
ça c'est une tarte à la crème pour les
romans ou pour les cinéastes ce qui est
l'expression de côte d'honneur voilà
mais non ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il y
avait jusqu'au aux alentours des années
2000 certains cursus professionnels chez
les voyous il y avait un déroulement de
carrière un plan de carrière comme dans
d'autres professions c'est à dire qui
démarrait au bas de l'échelle avec des
petits vols des cambriolages ils
attaquaient ensuite des petits braquages
des gros braquages voilà donc il y avait
une certaine progression dans le cursus
une certaine aristocratie du crime donc
il y a d'ailleurs un fichier du grand
banditisme avec des gens inscrits au
fichiers du grand monde ici
en partie disparu du fait de la
disparition d'une partie de ces
individus qui ont été
assassinés ou qui sont décédés d'autres
qui sont inc inspiré et en parallèle
au début des années 2000 on est une
génération que j'appelle dans mon livre
la génération kalachnikov
essentiellement présente dans les
banlieues qui elles
passent du vol de scooter au braquage
voilà et qui aussi a profité d'une
prolifération des armes puisque
jusqu'aux années 2000 les armes il y
avait assez peu d'armes en circulation
dès qu'un voyou était interpellé avec
une arme il était incarcéré et
maintenant il y a quand même une
circulation très importante du fait du
conflit en nexuslavie qui a permis
d'amener en France des tas d'armes avec
conflit en Ukraine on risque à avoir les
mêmes difficultés voilà et on a en fait
ces deux milieux qui cohabitent
actuellement voilà et
le danger de la réforme c'est que
les renforts de l'APJ ne viendront pas
forcément traiter la petite et moyenne
délinquance et à contrario les gros
voyous auront le champ libre
une question un peu plus personnelle
pour terminer et Joby que vous avez payé
si on peut dire ça comme ça votre
infiltration dans le milieu criminel
vous avez fait 17 jours de prison avant
d'être blanchi et indemnisé est-ce que
vous avez vu le métier de manière
différente après ça ça vous a marqué
alors oui non bon on sort pas tout à
fait un DM d'une telle expérience parce
que je suis passé de l'autre côté du
miroir j'ai été victime d'une
manipulation de voyous que nous avions
arrêté j'étais victime de l'erreur
judiciaire d'un juge d'instruction qui
m'a inculpé de proxénétisme qui m'a
incarcéré à tort quand j'avais 29 ans
voilà
mais déjà à l'époque j'ai toujours fait
confiance dans la justice puisque dans
mon affaire les magistrats du parquet de
la chambre d'accusation puis du tribunal
m'ont toujours
reconnu mon innocence donc je n'ai
jamais eu une inquiétude envers la
justice de mon pays
voilà ceci dit
ça m'a marqué oui forcément mais pour
autant j'ai continué à considérer que on
ne pouvait pas faire de bonnes poulies
judiciaires sans bons informateurs
vous racontez beaucoup de votre parcours
de vos anecdotes et de vos coups s'ils
devaient si vous ne devient retenir
qu'un quel est votre plus beau coup
alors le plus beau c'est difficile à
dire Olivier folle qui était le patron
du quai des Orfèvres qui d'ailleurs
avait eu qui m'avait fait l'honneur de
me nommer à la tête de la BRI deux trois
ans après on lui avait demandé quelles
sont pour vous les les affaires qui vous
ont marqué durant votre règne à la tête
du 36 il avait cité une affaire donc que
sur laquelle nous nous rejoignons qui
est l'affaire Boucheron qui était le
projet d'enlèvement donc du joaillier
Boucheron de la place Vendôme par une
équipe de malfaiteurs que nous avions
suivi pendant quatre mois malfaiteur qui
avait fait une soixantaine de repérages
donc sur le domicile du joaillier et
c'était une équipe complètement organisé
avec à la tête d'ailleurs un
intellectuel un braqueur mais
intellectuel qui avait une bibliothèque
chez lui très fournie avec des romans de
Roland Bart de Jean-Paul II en fait
c'était un profil assez atypique dans le
milieu voilà donc cette affaire-là qui
nous avait
occupé jour et nuit pendant 4 mois bon a
été une réussite totale et le préfet
d'ailleurs de police félima Sony était
venu féliciter
la BRI
qui a des Orfèvres pour son travail
de l'antigan flic indique écoute enduit
cette aux éditions plomb merci beaucoup
merci je vais être venu ce matin en fait
[Musique]